the simons institute uh my name is peter
bartlett i'm the associate director uh
welcome to
this richard m carp distinguished
lecture very happy to have you joining
us uh we established this series to
celebrate the role of simon's institute
founding director dick carp in
theoretical computer science
and the series features visionary
leaders
in tcs and in neighboring areas and it's
geared towards a broad scientific
audience
we're grateful to the many contributors
to the richard m carp fund who've made
the series possible
i'm really delighted to welcome our
speaker today uri feiger uri's professor
of computer science and applied
mathematics at the weitzman institute of
science he's had research positions at
princeton university
ibm tj watson research center and at the
microsoft
theory group microsoft research theory
group and he continues to serve as a
visiting researcher at microsoft
research in hertzler
his main research interests are
algorithms computational complexity and
algorithmic game theory he's won many
awards and prizes uh including the 2001
girdle prize for the pcp theorum and its
applications in hardness of
approximation
i'm very happy to have fury here today
his talks entitled uh finding large
cliques in random and semi-random graphs
join me in welcoming welcoming uh
[Applause]
so thank you it's a pleasure to be here
so the talk is finding large clicks in
random and semi-random graphs
let's start from the click problem so
the input is a graph with n vertices and
we an integer parameter k
and the question is whether this graph
contains a click of size k
so as we all know a click is a complete
sub graph that has all the edges so this
is a click of size 4.
and the k click problem is np complete
as we all know
so the topic of this talk is the maximum
click problem in random graphs
so the model that we have is a gnp er
deschreni random graph model
where every edge there are n vertices
and every edge is present independently
with probability p in our talk we limit
the discussion to equals half
so every edge is present with
probability half
in these graphs it's well known that the
largest clique with overwhelming
probability over the choice of graph
is of size roughly 2 log n logarithms 0
in base 2.
and a simple greedy algorithm finds a
click of size roughly log n just one log
n and the simple algorithm is if we can
random vertex remove all its
non-neighbors
and then recalls on the graph that
remains so in each step you gain a
vertex and
lose half the vertices so you get log n
vertices in the click
and i hope i got the u right but in 1976
apparently okay d carp asked
whether there's some value of epsilon
greater than zero
and a polynomial time algorithm that
with high probability finds a click of
size larger than log n one plus epsilon
log n in a random graph
so this is a long standing open problem
it's still open today
so i really have no solutions to tell
you about so i'll just tell you about
the
research that this question led to or
results that is related to this question
so the outline of the talk so again this
is the problem that we will be
considering
so
one aspect of the talk would be how do
you approach such a a question like what
kind of algorithms you
would be the first ones to try
so i'll discuss these algorithms
like
okay we'll get to them
they don't work
so then
we'll do what
we usually do in computer science we'll
slightly change the question
and try to answer related questions and
also there we'll see that we don't
always know the answers
um
so the things that present would not
necessarily be historical order they'll
know in some logical order
and of course many ref i will mention
some references but many additional
references will be omitted
okay
so the first approach to design an
algorithm to find an object that you
know exists is to
see how you prove that this object
exists and then see if the proof can be
made constructive
so we claim that in a random graph the
largest click is of type of the size
2 log n so how do we know that
and maybe we see how the proof goes from
this we can see find also an algorithm
that would find the click
so the proof is by a probabilistic
argument
so the expected number of clicks of size
k is exactly so this is an exact you
have look at all possible subsets of
size k of the vertices that's n shows k
and each one is a click with if all
edges are present this happens with
probability 2 to the minus k choose 2.
and if you do the computation if k is
larger than 2 log n up to lower order
terms that i ignore here
the expectation is less than one so we
don't expect to have any click there of
that size and if k is smaller than two
log n the expectation is greater than
one this by itself does not imply that
there's a click there
but since the variance can be shown to
also be small
is so that the standard deviation is
smaller than the expectation
then we know that with hypobit there is
a click there
so that's how we know that there are
clicks of size 2 log n halfway to log n
in random graphs
the question is can we make this
probabilistic argument constructive can
we change it into an algorithm so there
are probabilistic arguments that can be
made constructive a well-known example
is the lava slo colema
but for many other probabilistic
arguments we don't know how to translate
them into algorithms and this is one of
these arguments
because essentially all that it says is
that if you pick a random click a random
set of k purposes the probability that
they are a click
is a
2 to the minus k just 2.
so the algorithm that you try based on
this argument would just be sampling
random subsets of k vertices until you
get the click but this would take time
due to the khs 2 2 to the k square
roughly and this is too slow this is not
polynomial time
for our interest
for our value of k of interest here
so this would not work
okay another approach that
you should automatically try is to try
to see if maybe
the problem is easy even on worst case
instances
so our goal is to efficiently find the
click of size 1 plus epsilon log n in a
random graph that we know has a click of
size 2 log n
the question is maybe we can in every
graph that has a click of size to log n
find efficiently find the click of size
1 plus epsilon log n
possibly we can do it
and we know that this probability is p
this problem is probably not np hard
because even by exhaustive cells you can
solve it in time and to the other log n
and for np-half problems we don't expect
there to be algorithms of this running
time
so the problem is probably not empty
np-half
so can we solve it in polynomial time
so here are some examples of related
problems and this is relates to the area
of fixed parameter tractability
so here are other objects that you can
find in the graph more efficiently so if
you are looking for a simple path
uh
k vertices that form a path and do not
repeat themselves
then this can be found in time
polynomial in n
times
2 to the order k something exponential
in k but the k is not in the exponent of
the n it's in the exponent of the two
likewise a vertex cover can be find can
be found in this time
or also a click of size n minus k
instead of a click of size k can also be
found in this time so in fact
if you think about it this is a
essentially the vertex cover problem in
disguise
so maybe also click can be found in this
running time
and if it can be found in this running
time if we substitute the order log n
for k this is polynomial running time
let's see what algorithms we know for
finding clicks and is there any hope of
having an algorithm with such a running
time
so exhaustive search going over all
subsets of size k is
time roughly end to the k
still something better that we can do
you can we can list all maximal clicks
in a graph
in polynomial time per click
so if there are let's say only
polynomially many maximal click a click
is maximally it cannot be enlarged by
adding any vertex
if there are only polynomially many
maximal clicks we can list all of them
in polynomial time and find the maximum
clip
our random graph
the number of maximal clicks it's not
too difficult to show with something
like n to the half log n
so we can find the maximum click in time
and to the half log n the maximum click
is of size 2 log n
another algorithm that is useful for
finding clicks is fast matrix
multiplication
it doesn't give a big advantage but it's
a
very important in the sense that it
shows us that there are kind of ideas of
how to find clicks that seem to not be
related to clicks somehow
so we graph g we look at its adjacency
matrix
so if it has a triangle so a triangle is
a clip of size 3.
so then its trace if you raise the
matrix a to the power 3 and look at the
diagonal
then in the trace you have a non-zero
entry and a non-zero entry corresponds
to a triangle
and this you can detect
by doing a
fast matrix multiplication of a with
itself
and this takes time
faster than n cubed
so it's a n to the omega where omega is
some
the current constant for matrix
multiplication
and
so it's faster than n cubed and this can
be generalized to finding clicks of size
k in time roughly and to the omega over
3 which is smaller than 1 times k
so this shows that there are
like some kind of non-trivial algorithms
for finding clicks
but we have some evidence that there are
no that fix click is not fixed parameter
tactical in the sense that it cannot be
solved in time let's say polynomial in n
times some function of k
so one assumption that we can use is the
well-known exponential time hypothesis
and this hypothesis says that solving
three sat requires time really
exponentially in n
it's a stronger version of p naught
equals to np which just says that the
polynomial time does not suffice and the
same hypothesis says that the same holds
for a max click
like these problems are introducible to
each other
so if clicks of size log n can be found
in polynomial time
it can be shown that then max click can
be solved in time roughly two to the
let's say square root n and this would
contradict the exponential time
hypothesis i'll sketch a proof in the
next slide
there are other evidence that click is
not fixed parameter tractable
there is a notion of a hierarchy of
a
let's say hardness for
various problems and this click is the
click problem is complete for the first
level of this hierarchy which
it serves as evidence that it's
not cannot be solved in time
polynomial and n times some function k
so let me just briefly sketch the proof
so that's a relatively easy proof y if
you can find clicks of size log n in
polynomial time
this would contradict the exponential
time hypothesis so this is a rather
simple argument
so assume we have an algorithm that
finds clicks of size let's say n over 2.
so as the exponential time hypothesis
says that finding clicks of size n over
2 should take time
exponentially in n
how would we solve this problem
if we have a graph on any vertices in
which we want to find the click of size
n over 2 we'll construct a new graph on
many more vertices and to the other
square quote n vertices
this is the graph g prime
its vertices are subsets of vertices of
size squared and in the original graph
and
two such vertices are connected in by an
edge if together they form a click of
size two square root n so they have to
be disjoint sets of vertices that
together form a click of size to
well then
so it's quite easy to see that this
graph would have a click of size half
square root n
if and only if the original graph had a
click of size n over 2 because it have
half square root n times square root n
is n over 2.
okay so if in this original graph now
half square root n is log of the size of
the new graph
so if you can
solve
the task of finding log size click in
the new graph in time polynomial in the
size of the new graph this would be time
2 to the order of square root n log n
and would refute the exponential time
hypothesis
okay so we have evidence that
it's difficult in the worst case to find
clicks of size log n
another thing we might try to do is
approximation algorithms so let's denote
by omega of g the size of the maximum
click in a graph g
and we can ask is there some
approximation ratio rho which is larger
than half such that in every graph g not
just a random graph a click of size at
least
low times the maximum size can be found
in polynomial time
because if there is such an algorithm
all we are asking in our case is to find
the click slightly larger
than
half
a
the maximum size
when
in 1976 this question was open
by now using the pcp theorem in related
work we know that for any row greater
than zero the problem remains empty held
and using approach like i saw showed in
the previous slide this is also shows
that even if you try to approximate the
size of the maximum click when the
clicks are small like order log n
it's still you get the eth hardness
according to the exponential time
hypothesis so again you we don't expect
to have algorithms like this
so the summary so far is that
the question was is there some epsilon
and a polynomial time algorithm that
with high probability finds a click of
size one plus epsilon times log n in a
random graph
what we've seen if we assume the
exponential time hypothesis which maybe
again in 1976 people who maybe were not
willing to assume it i don't know by now
we are willing to assume it
uh
then such an algorithm if it exists
we'll have to make use of the fact that
the input graph is random it cannot work
for war spacecrafts
we try to use the fact that they algo
that the input graph is random by
inspecting the proof of how we know that
random graphs have large clicks or not
so large of size order again
but this argument also does not
translate into any useful algorithm
so we need some fresh ideas here
any questions so far
okay
okay so let's re-examine the algorithm
that finds clicks of size roughly log n
and see if we understand it really and
understand its limitations so here's the
simple algorithm you pick a vertex at
random put it in your click and remove
all its known neighbors and repeat this
is the algorithm that i described
and roughly in each step the size of the
graph decreases by a factor of 2 so you
find the click of size log n
the running time of this algorithm is
really order and even though the graph
is to describe the graph you need n
square bits to describe
which between every pair of vertexes if
you have an edge really the running time
is only order n because in the first
step you pick a random vertex look at
its neighbor so that's n steps
and then in the next step you have only
a graph of size n over two and so on so
you have a geometric series and the
running time is order n
if you're willing to spend more time you
can have a marginal improvement but not
significant instead of picking an
arbitrary vertex a random vertex
in its step pick the vertex of highest
degree because then you have the most
vertices remaining this does the change
in the result is very marginal
insignificant and the running time
increases to n square just to find the
vertex of highest degree just for the
first step
okay so it's probably not worth the
problem
and they
bother to do it
so here's an improved algorithm which is
somewhat better
so it's like the previous algorithm but
we stopped early so we repeat the
process until n prime vertices remain
and i chose n prime to be 2 to the power
of square root 2 log n okay n prime
so we select each time a random vertex
remove its non-neighbors but we stop
bend when the number of vertices that
remain is n prime
and this at this point we switch to a
different algorithm
so when n prime vertices remain the size
of the largest click there is two log of
n prime
so for what i chose it's 2 square root 2
log n
and now we switch to the algorithm of
enumerating all clicks in this graph
so the running time of that algorithm
was n prime to the half log n prime
which is all the ends still linear in n
and we find the maximum click in this
subgraph that remain so instead of
extracting from this subgraph that
remain a click of only size log n prime
as the gradient go with the model we
extract this click of size 2 log n prime
so
using this we gain a log n prime
so the we find the click of size log n
plus log n prime which
gains us
a square root to log n low order term
so this algorithm uses a paradigm that
for this talk i'll call it the max in
neighborhood paradigm
okay
so what does the algorithm really do you
find a random click k1 of size little k1
let's say by the greedy algorithm this
was the first step of the algorithm and
we will choose the value of this k1
such that the neighborhood of it
is sufficiently small so that you have
enough resources to find in it the
maximum click so you find the maximum in
this neighborhood the maximum click in
the neighborhood that's k2 and we'll
return the union of the two
okay so this is the algorithmic paradigm
used by these particular algorithms
so if your resources are ordered in time
make sure that you can find the click of
size log n plus squared of 2 log n
if you allow yourself polynomial time
you don't gain much you just in the
second order term instead of
2 square
just the constant changes in front of
the squad log n
so this is the paradigm that we use
so
we can ask ourselves
for a given amount of resources is this
neighborhood paradigm optima let's say
up to negative eligible terms or can you
improve upon it
we would like to answer this question
when the resource is the running time
but we don't know
enough about computation we don't
understand computation well enough to
answer this question for example if we
would prove that it's optimal we prove
that p is different than np so
we are far away from showing that it is
optimal
but this is a computational problem what
can computation do we can change it to
an easier problem which is an
informational problem so this is what we
do now
and this informational problem we may be
able to answer
so we look at a certain probe model from
a paper with a also also with prasad we
started studying it and there were
additional work
so here the situation is different we
have no limit on computation time but we
don't know the graph we can probe
entries in its adjacency matrix and get
information about the graph and we are
limited in how much information we can
get so a pair a probe you ask for a pair
i j two vertices and then reply you are
told if there's an edge between them or
not
and we pay only for these probes we
don't pay for computation
and we need to find the
click as large as possible
so if you had n choose two probes you
could
probe the whole adjacency matrix and
find the maximum click because there's
no bound on your computation time
then the question is what happens if you
have only linear number of order n not
order n squared
so certainly you can find the clique of
size at least log n plus
this square root of 2 log n because we
had a linear time algorithm that found
it so this linear r time algorithm could
not look at more than linear number of
edges in the graph so this is certainly
something that you can do and the
question is can you do better
so what would you do let's say if you
had to do all the probes in parallel
okay no adaptivity at all okay so you
can take a set of square root and
vertices ask about all the edges inside
learn the complete graph the whole graph
on these two vertices this graph has a
side
as the click of size 2
a log of the size of t so it's two log
square root n which is log n
so you'd find the click of size log n in
one round
what happens if you allow yourself more
and more adaptivity more rounds
then we show we saw that in one round
you can find log n
click of size log n in two rounds will
not
show this you can find a click of four
thirds log n in thriller
yeah so in the second round the
questions can depend on the answers from
the first round
in three rounds almost three log n up to
low order terms a three halves
log n and if you don't bound the number
of rounds we know how to find a clicks
of size uh
three halves log n
all these algorithms i'll show the one
for three rounds in a minute all these
algorithms are based on the same maxi
neighborhood
paradigm that they explained before
all the rounds except for the last one
find the random click k1
and the set t of squared and neighbors
and in the last round you query this set
t and find the click of size log n
and this is what you return the clicks
that you found in the first rounds union
with this last clip
for example the one round algorithm
really what it does it finds the empty
like a
the k1 is empty there's nothing there
and just finds k2
so let's see the three around algorithm
first in the slide then in pictures yes
let's get to it yeah okay
okay so let me sketch the algorithm for
three rounds and also show it later in a
picture
so in round one you find some arbitrary
click a random click of size half log n
how do you do that we know that you can
find the click of size logan in one
round so
you can certainly take just half logan
of the vertices
now in the second round you try to find
a neighborhood which vertices are
connected to all vertices of your clique
so since you have only order n probes in
the second round and the clickers
already of size half log n so you take a
set of n over log n vertices and query
all the edges between this set s
and the all click k1
and find within this set s the set of t
verb and set t which are those vertices
that are neighbors of all of k1
and the size of t is going to be
something like square root n over log n
with high probability
and then you ask about all pairs inside
t and find the maximum click in t
so if you do the computation the maximum
clicking t is of size log n minus a low
order term
and all together you found the click of
sides three halves log n minus all the
log log n
let's do it just again in a picture
so it's the first you find this click k1
besides half log n in your graph
then you take a set s
such that you have enough probes
available to ask about all edges between
s and k 1 so s has to be of size roughly
n over log n and you ask about all these
edges
this is in the second round
in the output of the second round you
discover the set t all the vertices
which are neighbors of all of k1
and then in the third round you ask
about all edges inside t and find the
maximum click there which is k2
and you
return the union of the two
so it's also
this maxi neighborhood paradigm where in
round three you find the maximum click
in t
so we can ask whether in the in the
computational model that we started with
we did not know if the maxim
neighborhood paradigm is optimal but we
can ask is it optimal in the probe mode
if your limitation is the number of
probes not the computation time
so for one one round we know that it's
optimal but you cannot find something
larger than log n click larger than log
n
for two rounds we also know that it's
optimal that you cannot find something a
click larger than four thirds log n
for three rounds we don't know we have
an upper bound of the 1.6 instead of 1.5
1.62
and if you allow an arbitrary number of
rounds we know how to find the clicks of
size
three halves log n and the upper bound
is roughly 1.7 log n
then on october
so we don't have tight bounds
so let me just explain
the upper bound for the one round case
because the
it's the simplest of all upper bounds
they get much more complicated as your
head rounds
but it contains any ingredient that is
used in all proofs
okay
so let's say here let's call the number
of probes
q doesn't have to be n the same argument
works regardless of the value of q
if we will substitute for q the value of
n we'll get this upper bound of log n
okay so what do we know we know that our
algorithm returns the clicks of size k
so it must have probed all the edges of
this click otherwise how would it know
that it is a click okay if enough that
it did not pop one edge
and with probability half it's already
not a click
okay so it pulled all the edges of the
click
if it bombed all the edges of the click
it also probed a maximum matching inside
this clip so the click is of size k it
has a matching of size k over two so k
over two edges that touch all the
vertices let's for simplicity assume
that k is even
so this matching is incident with all
vertices of the click
so given the pro pattern this you select
non-adaptively the first round you
select what what edges you're going to
pull probe
you know that if you're going to return
a click
a k over 2 of the edges of your probe
will touch all the vertices of the click
so there are only q choose
k over 2 possibilities of which are the
vertices of the click
and then each such click each such set
of k vertices is the click with
probability 2 to the minus k over 2.
so if uh this product
for the algorithm to succeed it must be
that this product is larger than one and
if you plug in values for q you get
a tight bounce so
for one round you get the tight bounce
for two rounds alco the argument is
considerably more
complicated and for three rounds we
don't know how to make it tight
okay
so summary of the pope model
so maxi neighborhood is the best
algorithm we know for finding clicks in
random graphs when the limiting resource
is running time we have no idea how to
prove that it is optimal
but when the limiting resource is the
number of probes we can prove its
optimality if there's limited
adaptivity up to two rounds
and for more rounds we have non-trivial
bounds so there's hope maybe that will
be able to determine if it's optimal or
not
ideally we'll find that it's not optimal
and get new ideas of how to also use
algorithms in the computational setting
but we don't know
so back to bounded computation time
so we said that the size of the maximum
click omega g is likely to be two log n
but for the given input graph that you
have you don't know if it's too low
again really it can be any size it's a
random graph who knows what the coin
tosses gave
so we discussed algorithms that foremost
on the graphs efficiently find the
clique of size log n and hence they
certify that the size of the maximum
click is at least log n
you can ask about refutation for what
value of k do we know that there's no
click larger than k
like how can you efficiently certify
that there's no click larger than k this
is like a co and p statement
that there's no solution
so how do we do that
so here
we look at a variation on the adjacency
matrix of the graph
so i'll call this matrix the a of g
and for a graph it's a symmetric n by n
matrix where it's indexed the rows and
columns by the vertices of the graph
and
along the diagonal we put ones
and
whenever there's an edge if there's an
edge between vertex i and j we choose
one that's like the adjacency matrix and
if there's no edge we put minus one
instead of zero
which we put in the adjacency matrix
and if we have a click
of k by k click in the graph a k click
then it will give a combinatorial block
of all one so let me show it in a
picture
so let's say this is our graph a very
simple graph with four vertices and this
is the matrix that we construct so the
diagonal is all one whenever there's an
edge let's say between vertex one and
two so entry
the second enter in the first row is one
and when there's no edge let's say
between vertex three and four so the
fourth entering the
third row is minus one okay so that's
the matrix
and if i look at any click let's say the
triangle
it forms a block a combinatorial square
block of all ones okay combinatorial in
the sense that it doesn't have to be
consecutive after rearranging the rows
and columns it becomes a block
so let's now go to spectral graph theory
which is very useful here so this deals
with eigenvalues of matrices associated
with graphs so this matrix here is one
of these matrices
and this is useful algorithmically
spectral graph theory because
eigenvalues are correlated with some
graph properties that are np hard for
example we show okay we'll get there
yet eigenvalues can be computed in
polynomial time so sometimes when
completing eight you can values you
learn something
which otherwise is difficult to learn
about the graph
so here's the fact that you can prove
using rayleigh quotients i will not go
over the proof that if a symmetric
matrix like our matrix a g
has a k by k block of all ones then
necessarily the largest eigenvalue of
the symmetric matrix is at least k
that's not difficult to prove it
consequently
since we said that this matrix a g has a
block
a k by k block of all one if there's a
click of says k it means that the
largest eigen value of this matrix is at
least as large
as the maximum click
in the graph
now we have a random graph and a lot is
known about eigenvalues of random graphs
so we know
that if we take a random graph like g
and half that we are using here and
construct this matrix a a g
with overwhelming probability its
largest eigenvalue is going to be 2
roughly 2 square root n
so using this we can certify that
the input graph that we have does not
have a click larger than 2 square root n
we compute the largest eigenvalue
it will go it's going to be 2 square
root 10 and we know from before that
that's an upper bound on the size of the
maximum click
okay so we can ask can we do better than
this
so here's an improved upper bound by
using convex programming
uh
so again if we are going to construct a
matrix from the graph but we are not
going to
specify all entries some entries will
optimize over them
so we'll have the matrix m
it's going to be an nba and symmetric
matrix
also
indexed by the vertices the rows and the
columns are indexed by the vertices of
the graph
and we want to minimize its maximum
eigen
value subject to the following
constraints along the diagonal we put
all ones
and whenever there's an edge we put a
one so we maintain the property that
there's a block
of all ones if there's a click of size k
there's a block of all ones of size k
this property will maintain and all
other entries are free you can do
whatever you want with them
and you solve a convex problem that will
find what values to put there so as to
minimize the largest eigenvalue
so this can be computed
so it's a context problem and in fact it
can be computed using semi-definite
programming
so a
relatively easy type of context for
let's say programming
so here's an example let's say this was
our graph and the corresponding matrix a
g that we had before
what changes now
is that
the entries that used to be -1
now i leave them free
okay the algorithm can choose whatever
it wants to put them in order to
minimize the largest eigenvalue
okay so this quantity is very much
related to the lowest stata function
so we'll refer to this value lambda 1 of
this matrix m as
theta bar of g so not theta of g why
because it's really the complement of
the tata function of lobas for those who
know of this function
so the lowest stata function has many
many formulations and this is one of
them for the edge complement of g for
the complement graph
so we call it about this quantity
and for every graph we have that this
data bar
is larger
than at least as large as the largest
click
because there's this block of all ones
that limits how much we can reduce the
maximum eigenvalue
in the data function where it was
originally defined it was for the
complement graph so it was a larger than
the largest independent set
but we are with that about here
and we know that it's smaller
not
not larger than the largest eigenvalue
of this matrix a g because we can
minimize where we put the question mouse
we can put whatever we want and we
minimize
lambda one so we're only improving
so it's a tighter upper bound on omega g
than the first eigenvalue of h is
okay
so let's see a picture
so this is a plot made by a vadim
greenberg
so what do we see here in this plot
so each point is a random graph
generated
with
50 vertices
that's each point so we have many points
here and for each point the
x coordinates says what the value like
of the teta function is what the
semi-definite program gives
whereas the y-axis says what's the
maximum eigenvalue of this matrix a g
without any optimization
so what do we see in this picture
so we see that if we look at the maximum
eigenvalue it's between let's say 11 and
a half and 15 that's the range of value
that you have
but if you look at the
the value of this data function you'll
get better upper bounds between nine and
six point something so there's an
improvement
there's something a bit strange about
this picture the points look scattered
nicely but there are these vertical
lines here so does anybody know what
these vertical lines are
so remember that the tether function is
an upper bound on the size of the
maximum click
in these graphs the maximum click was of
size nine
if not for that
these points would have moved left
and here they were of size eight
and like here these two points are of
size
seven and apparently there were a few
graphs where the maximum click was
smaller than six probably five
okay so we we see that the data function
does a better job than the maximum
eigenvalue
and in fact in this graph sometimes it
really tells us what's the size of the
maximum clip
so yes
you can check it
it's not so easy that yeah because
if you want many simulations and you
want to check all of them but they
actually mentioned
[Music]
do you think what algorithm you use
maybe the one listing or the clicks
okay so what do we know so despite the
nice success that we had for graphs of
size 50 this was an artifact of checking
it on size 50
because the the value of the theta
function can be shown to be at least
squared n for random graphs
so this love has already showed and the
later paypal
showed a weaker bound but for gnp not
enough
okay so and the maximum click of a size
2 log n so this upper bound is not very
good
and
we can strengthen this upper bound
because it's a context program so we can
build various hierarchies on top of this
uh convex
program like there's the shiraeli adam's
therapy the lava shriver hierarchy some
of squares here is there are many
hierarchies ways systematic ways of
adding constraints
so what do we find
so it will usually go t levels up in
this hierarchy
what they do is reduce the upper
boundary factor of two to the order t
but the running time that they use is
something like n to the omega t so you
spend much more running time for each
factor of two let's say for each factor
of two that you literally use you spend
a factor of n more time
so you cannot go beyond the constant t
in the remaining polynomial time and
this is still omega of
square root n
so this is a
does not seem to give us very much
and in fact if you are willing to spend
time and to the omega t you don't need
any of these hierarchies the simpler
algorithms that would refute would show
that there are no clicks of size
square root n divided by 2 to the t you
don't need a convex product coming at
all just branch and bound and
eigenvalue computations would do it for
you
okay so now to the last topic
so let's make
now the problem easier the one of
finding a click of size a one plus
epsilon log n
so we'll go we'll move to the planted
model
so we'll generate first the graph like
from g and half yes
that's what we know so like there are
various proofs showing let's say that
particular hierarchies would not do
better than this or something similar to
that let's say for the lobus river
hierarchy we have exactly this picture
for the sum of squares hierarchy
approximately this picture
we know for specific algorithms that
they don't work we don't have a proof
no
okay
so here we are moving to the planted
clique problem so we start with just a
random g and half graph but we call it g
prime because we are going to change it
and now we plant in it a click of size k
what does it mean we select k distinct
vertices independently at random and add
to g all missing edges between terms of
vertices
so this gives the graph g
and the goal is now in this graph we
planted another click maybe now it's
easier to find the clique of size one
plus epsilon log n
this is what we are trying to do
so for what values of k is it feasible
if k is equal to n of course you can do
it easily because the whole graph is a
click if k is equal to 1 it didn't help
you all the what we did here so probably
for some value at the middle it should
help you
now if k is larger than two log n then
with high probability k in fact the
planted click is the unique maximum
click
and then in the graph and then you can
also ask can you find this
unique maximum click in polynomial time
so information
is there can you
find it in a computational way
so what are the known results so one
kind of rule of thumb okay it's not a
theorem
that if you'd be able to find the click
of size one plus epsilon log n in the
planted model and k is large enough then
also you'd find the planted clip okay
these are essentially the same problem
okay
so now what do we know about finding the
planted clique so there's another rule
of thumb that it's essentially the
values of k for which you can find the
planet click are those for which the
refutation worked
that these problems are roughly the same
okay so there are many algo we showed
that refutation works when the size of
the click is a constant times square
root n
and there are many algorithms that would
find the planted clique if this is its
size so there are spectral algorithm we
also saw our spectral algorithms for
refutation
once based on the lowest data function
we also saw the those for reputation
there are other algorithms like message
passing algorithms but also can find the
planted click
when the size of the blended clique is
little or squared and we don't know
anything
okay we don't know of any polynomial
time algorithm
so have we made progress here so we use
some sophisticated algorithm to find the
planted clique
so it seems that progress is not very
great
because if then if you take just the
simple algorithm of picking the k
vertices of highest degree this already
finds for you the planted clique when
the size of the planted click is
slightly more than square root n squared
n times log n
so it's a very simple algorithm a
variation on it walking backwards
removing the vertices of lowest degree
one by one iteratively
already finds the planted clique when
the size of the planted click is a
constant times square with n so
algorithms that to know you
do not use any spectral graph theory or
any convex programming or anything
essentially perform as well as the best
algorithms that we know
so it seems that we did not make much
progress
so we can ask what advantages do the
most sophisticated algorithms offer us
so there are two answers
so one regarding the semi-definite
programming based algorithms and perhaps
also the spectral algorithms this was
not worked out i think
they can certify that the click that
they return is indeed the largest in the
input graph
okay so you don't just find out to the
click and say this is the blended click
you also certify there's no larger click
there
and that's an advantage
the other kind of advantage
comes when you look at what's known as
semi-random models and the issue of
robustness
okay so the planted click model is a
purely random model the exact input
distribution is known
in semi-random models the adversary
there's some adversary which typically
is not computationally bounded has
partial control over the input
distribution so let me give two examples
there are others
one example would be a monotone
adversary
so you planted the random clique in a
graph and then that versa can inspect
the graph
and remove edges which are not inside
the click
somehow it should make finding the click
easier in some sense because
it's somehow hinting to you that it
cannot be that both these vertices are
in the click it gives you hints
okay another example would be the
adversarial hidden click so that
versailles can inspect the random graph
g in half before planting the click and
decide where to plant the click in the
graph
rather than plan choosing k vertices at
random that vel so he chooses k vertices
that's another semi-random model
so do algorithms extend to semi-random
models
so if we look at the monotone adversary
it easily fools many of the algorithms
so the degree based algorithms the one
that takes the largest degree vertices
or the load removal are easily fooled by
these algorithms spectral algorithms are
pulled by this argo by these adversaries
standard message passing algorithms are
full
so in a sense it tells us that these
algorithms were over fitted to the
particular distribution if you change
the distribution a little they fail
but if you look at algorithms based on
semi-definite programming on the lower
standard function they are not fooled by
this adversary
okay so we so
in a sense
we show that these algorithms are better
more robust
why should we study semi-random models
so there are like two reasons one is
particle significance it adds robustness
to average case analysis so algorithms
that work for semi-random models cover a
wider range of instances that those are
just work for under models and the other
is theoretical convenience once we have
a mixture of an adversary and randomness
because we have an adversary there's a
chance of proving hardness results
and for some of the semi-random models
we have np hardness results that explain
why we don't find algorithms
for there's no random model in which we
have an np hardness result but for
semi-random models we have so sometimes
we know
like if we hit a wall we know that it's
really a wall
okay so let me end with
okay so what have we seen
so
the question was to find clicks of size
one plus epsilon log n in a random graph
and there's really no significant focus
on this problem in 45 years
uh we can ask an easier question finding
clicks of size one plus epsilon log a
log n not in random graphs with graphs
with a planted click of much larger size
so in the g and half k model
there's only marginal progress over
trivial algorithms
we only succeed when k is equal to
square root n and this can be done by
really simple algorithms
and this is among the easiest
examples of computation information gap
where like in terms of information
there's this huge click inside that
waits for you to find it but we don't
know how to find it
and they
like in a formal way it's among the
easiest problems because there are
reductions from this problem to many
other problems
and the most significant
progress in my opinion that we have is
in the area of robustness that we have
now algorithms that work not just in
random models but can work in
semi-random models
so i'll end with two open questions both
on the same slide
okay so i mentioned the probe model
and i said that for two rounds
we know that the bounds that we have our
optimal so this was not exactly correct
if you allow not
n posts to the graph but enter the three
half post to the graph
two rounds then the maxi neighborhood
algorithm would find the click of size
you can do the computation seven over
four times log n
and we don't know if it's optimal and
you can wonder what's the difference
between n two to three halves probes and
endpoints y would for one thing
version proving a lower bound upper
bound be easier than the other
if you start playing with it you'll see
okay oh ask me later
and another
problem that i find quite intriguing is
the following a
semi-random model
so we saw
we ask for example what happens if an
adversary plants a click in
a
random graph and plant it whatever you
want there's the alternative question
of let's say the adversary chooses
whatever graph you want
okay
and now you plant in it
select k vertices at random and make
them into a click
and the question is in this graph can
you find a click of size k you might not
be able to find the planted clique
because let's say you started with a
graph that was a clique and obviously
you wouldn't know which vertices are the
planted clear
but
like
it seems obviously difficult but i don't
know how to show that this is a
difficult problem
so we have an arbitrary graph plant
a random k click in it can you find the
click of sizegate
okay so i'll end here
questions
the hypothesis this is the gn half k
model so we know it's either doable when
k is like
order square root n so when k say sort
of like little o square root n if you
make the hypothesis this is a hard
problem does it have any interesting
consequences or okay so i myself not
sure that i'm willing to make the
hypothesis no just as a but yes there
are various papers that make this
assumption and based on this uh
because like what really happens here so
the way people i mean this is the whole
field of making hypothesis we have a
certain algorithm that we know okay
like let's say semi-definite programming
specs or whatever
you find your favorite problem you try
all the algorithms that you know and you
hit a barrier you cannot improve over it
and then you can make the hypothesis
that you hit a barrier because there's
nothing else because really at the
different density let's say the problem
is difficult
and then in a sense you're saying these
are all the algorithms that we know
there's no new algorithm to discover and
then from this you can make reductions
sometimes to other problems and say also
there
we now understand why there's a barrier
so
in a sense uh
like
there's a systematic way of making up
hypotheses and proving consequences
it's not always easy sometimes you need
very clever reductions
but
like all of them i think really say that
the kind of algorithms that we know now
are optimal
and if you make this assumption you
usually can have consequences
yeah can you give us some insight into
why you believe this rule of thumb one
that you can if you can find one plus
epsilon times log n size in the
productive model so here's some
intuition why i would believe it
so let's say first that
even without planting a click
you can find clicks of size one plus
epsilon log n in this case i don't make
any claims because maybe you know the
algorithm will just find clicks anyway
nothing to do with the planted
but suppose that finding clicks of one
plus epsilon log n is difficult
in random graphs once you do the
planting it becomes easy
so if it becomes easy it must be that at
least log epsilon
log n of the vertices came from the
planted clique
because otherwise you just take your
random graph planting it a click where
you know where it is maybe upsize the k
find the click of size one plus epsilon
log n and remove the vertices from the
old clip from the planted click there so
you find something larger than let's say
one plus epsilon number so you know that
let's say at least epsilon over two log
n came from the oakley
so once you know it
like you can guess which vertices they
are
there are not so many possibilities out
of log n to choose epsilon log n that's
not many possibilities less than n okay
and for each guess once you guess them
you remove all their non-neighbors and
recurs
so if you do an algorithm like this
you'd be able to find the blended clip
cool cheers thanks
thanks for the talk
um
i was wondering whether it's uh
looking at the erdogan graph was like
the most interesting one or
is there like a similar results for a
different type of
random graphs
like i don't know geometry graphs or
configuration models or whatever so i
think
it's interesting also to look at other
graphs and sometimes it's
um
people have looked at it sometimes the
reason people look at other graphs is
because let's say if you're interested
in social networks people don't believe
that they're the any graphs capture
the structure
but this kind of problem
the nice thing about it is that it's
like simple to state and
you know that people tried everything on
it
so
like if you're looking for you know a
tough problem
it's nice to look at it but if you're
really looking at applications then of
course
it's interesting to look at other graphs
last question
[Music]
yeah thank you very much uh so in your
first
endeavor to find max clicks one plus
epsilon again in the g and half
you said that like uh do we have any
understanding of positive results for
positive temperature so like not just
greedy methods but like metropolis
saying like do we know if it can reach
logan plus square root again
or like uh because i know the zero
negative result but i'm not aware of
yeah okay so the world is negative
results by each one
my feeling is that the algorithms that
we know
like if you try to make gradual
improvement like there's something
related to this overlap gap property or
something like that
if you look at the clicks of size let's
say of yourself and size
they don't tell you how to find clicks
of larger size because most of them
like our maxima in the sense wants you
which sizes above logan
so it's very difficult to apply
algorithms
like
they don't even tell you that in the
vicinity there's a
larger click so
it's difficult to apply these things
all right join me in thanking you
fascinating too
[Applause]